hey guys right right here hi Lauren got
here so we're gonna watch a video called
the slap is a pretty popular video get
slapped or else I'll be pleased
yeah I don't know if this is part 2 or
part 1 I know I heard there's like two
different ones but anyway I don't know
what it's about so Lauren what are we
doing this is watch it's it's turn it on
man
what are you waiting for it's gonna
happen whoa Lauren Lauren you can't talk
over the video like I'm sorry I was like
waiting for you to turn on I know but
then you were talking to I press the
spacebar but in a place sorry I was
still talking after you presses press
the spacebar but Lauren I'm not gonna
have this argument with you in front of
the camera everything that's gonna
happen to be determined between you on
camera okay okay
who's it in I'm Ryan Ryan right that's
me Morgan see you go first this is way
better than the strangers kissing I'm
Chloe
really nice to meet you you too Oh
awesome one hi Daniel nice to meet you
okay okay
you look nice um yeah uh-huh so uh this
oh hey Jimmy
so let me slap each other yeah have to
take off my glasses in forehand I'm
gonna take my jacket off okay I would
take the Rings off too oh yeah I've been
here before
a couple times have you once
no how do we start this stretch up Scott
intimate do you wanna go first
oh [ __ ] oh that wasn't that was a good
one
oh I can't here now yeah do it again do
it again can't we keep hitting each
other you men do it again
I'll get you again yeah yeah let's go
you didn't really know you never said
okay we got that one slap out and now
we're slaps before a nuts man Oh
oh wow that was awesome and hilarious
that's awesome
and like they vetted everyone you seen
the strangers kissing one right no oh
it's the same thing that happened I
don't remember when it came out but it's
like they asked however many strangers
to kiss for the first time and it's the
same thing but they're kissing it throws
we're still older still oh no Joseph I
Lauren we got you it go for it
I don't want you to slap me now I'm not
gonna slap you I wouldn't ever slap a
girl since some of the pears no one was
like boy we're all like this isn't fair
and that you can really tell the
difference between someone like being
nice and someone just like going for it
yeah we gotta just laughing okay I could
do a little harder I didn't really hate
you that I know I could go a little
harder and you hit my neck to scratch my
neck Thanks I did pretty good kung-fu
skills you don't have good aim when
someone is this close to you but you
actually like dodged it all right those
lions okay all right ready
this is just like weirder yeah it's just
trying yeah I don't want to be part of
the slap I got slapped yes yes that was
cool as cool Lauren nice man that was
most physical you know contact you ever
had I'm gonna think about this tonight
you don't like to get slapped during sex
- you
no hun guys Maitri what smoking the only
to get spanked soon the guys Gary please
turn clap really I just like wasn't
expecting it
I wasn't like I wasn't ready for it I
don't know it took me it took me by
surprise
so both girls like that I think at least
ones I've encountered I I once had sex
with someone who like really slapped me
hard in the face Wow
his really argh interesting first time
really hot
the next time who was like did not
expect it and it was really hard and I
kind of got irritated but I kept going
okay mm-hmm you know who you are if
you're watching you're probably not
watching good no no you guys are gonna
subscribe subscribe subscribe and you
can subscribe to Lauren's channel
what are you set board from starters sad
scribe Chris Sears posted a video on his
birthday years
this is recently when I posted a couple
days ago yay happy birthday Kris happy
birthday Sears happy birthday to you you
live in a zoo you smell like a monkey
Hey No and you look like one too you
know that was brilliant
that was good that's good that's how you
get Sears do you work at Sears now be
cool if you worked at Sur - you do on
Sears to be part of this Sears heritage
are you gonna inherit a Sears and take
more money once one Sears store yeah
Sears has suits and refrigerators yeah
so that's another friend and I went to
Sears because he needed to buy an air
mattress and they didn't have air
mattresses like Sears damn it Chris I
have bought all your fault
happy birthday hope you get a lot of
[ __ ] angel Gomez angel Gomez can I get
a shout out or she have they already got
no definitely not angels angels the
standout name can i get a shoutout well
angel
girl that could be either right yeah I
mean if you're a girl what's up angel
you're beautiful you're like a shining
heavenly star if you're a guy you have a
girl's name Christian Renetta bro I love
your videos hilarious as [ __ ] you sir
what oh you meant to put a pause
hilarious is [ __ ] you sir having these
periods I know you have the support of
the Samoan Tongan army cheer whoa are
you the leader of the Samoan Tongan czar
me whoa dude that's huge if you're even
just part of it man that'd be pretty
cool actually cool beans
who are you guys fighting are you guys
at war do you know anything about
Samoans no I know a guy who was part
Samoan you might be related to you buddy
he might be related to you just like how
all Asians are related although really
you could say all human beings are
really technically yeah I mean we are
from Adam and Eve descent or evolved
monkeys you're treading on territory you
really don't want to do with me Lauren I
will demolish his name's Christian for
cryin Ella
he's a Christ believer you believe in
Christ right he doesn't but his parents
do it so it doesn't matter it's always
interesting that I meet a guy named
Christian who's an atheist cuz it's like
it would be more erotic to meet a
Christian who is Jewish ah
cuz they specifically don't believe in
Christ that's what Jews are known for
that's what they are known for yeah
they're know that and having big noses
and making lots of money curly hair more
offensive more offensive material for
you guys uh I don't know any stereotypes
about Samoans my friend whatever they're
large you're a large human being yeah
Christian Samoan what's for last name
Christian Renata
you're a large Samoan my friend
congratulations on completing the Samoan
stereotypes